Speaker 1: Let's go next to Sam
from Minnesota. Sam, welcome to
the program. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 4: Hi. I'm remembering when you
talked about Latin acts a little while ago.
Yes. I mean, I never understood why people say.
In that way, Latin X instead of like Latino,
Latino Latin acts like Kleenex. I wouldn't
use it myself, but if I did, I would use it.
Speaker 1: Yellows in the pronunciation is the
least of my concerns with it. I'll tell you that.
Speaker 4: Right. Exactly. Exactly.
I want to hear your opinion as a Latino about
what I think is realistically the alternative
to that. The English language doesn't have a
lot of gender terms, and some of the ones it
does are going away like actor, actress or
just is just actor now for a lot of people.
Yeah. So I think the most likely outcome
is that it's Latino. There is no Latina,
everything's Latino. So if I'm right,
what do you think of that? And second,
do you think I'm right or wrong?
Speaker 1: So I am going to opt out of the
prediction part. We're just humans are terrible
at making predictions. What do I know? Maybe
your idea is, if I understand it correctly, is as
follows Instead of adding a gendering third word
instead of Latino for male and Latina for female
Latin X or Latin x. Okay. You're saying Latino is
used by everyone so it simply no longer denotes
gender. Hi. I'm a Latino woman. I'm a Latino man.
It's all Latino. That's that's the idea. I have
absolutely no idea whether that will happen. And
I have no interest whatsoever in making it
happen. But what I will say is the following
It should come from the community. It shouldn't
be imposed by mostly non Latino Americans because
it's right or better right. It should come
from the ground up. If Spanish speakers
all over the Spanish speaking world decide we
want to do that, then sure do it. But for me,
it's working fine the way it is right now.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah. I don't know if it'll
happen in Spanish. I just think
it'll happen that way in English.
Speaker 1: Oh, in English.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah. Yeah. So.
So Spanish can do whatever it wants, but, like,
if you're talking in English. Yeah. You know,
I think that as an English speaker, it's
just going to be Latinos, everything.
Speaker 1: I thought it already
was that way in English. I
never hear anyone in English say Latina.
Speaker 4: Well, I don't know. I you know,
I hear people speaking English and they'll
say Latino. But maybe they're using it in a
Spanish way, for lack of a better word. All
right. So, yes, I haven't heard that. Hmm.
Well, I don't know. Yeah.
Speaker 1: It's an interesting
idea. Interesting idea. All right.
Very good. Thank you for the call.
Well, they seem to be gone already. Boy,
all sorts of crazy stuff going on today.